[Music]
is this true that you and your sister
went to kind of an unusual high school
is that right
it's kind of more of a permissive
creative high school is that fair to say
no dress code it was kind of a
hippie school there were you know kids
were named willow and echo and ivy and
boston and asia and things like that
america
i didn't know uh hippie names were also
like city names yeah
that i think was like the newest i think
those are the younger kids they
became city names baltimore get over
here
where they were they did but you had to
learn the same stuff that other
schools learn right you had to learn
math and science and all those things it
was all just like hey man i'm not
feeling it you know
well it's both it's a college
preparatory school but it we also had a
class called mysteries which is like
group therapy and it was based on
native american rituals so you have a
talking stick and you can only talk if
you have the talking stick and the other
people can only say ho
ho what do you mean ho ho ho means i
agree with you i understand oh i thought
you meant like ho like you know hey
shut up po you
know it's like i don't like this
permissive school
uh and i have to make bones i can't
believe it's in its eighth season
eighth season yeah people love the show
uh
congratulations bones airs monday nights
at eight on fox and congratulations on
your what's your boy's name henry henry
very cool all right yeah andy was on our
show do you know that
no he moonlighted
no no no
before you and i got back together
when you were taking a break
you're supposed to tell me about all
your exes i have an outside life
we'll talk about this in the commercial
break
maybe i'll go off and do some things on
my own
no one wants me to
emily chanel thank you so much